c'est surtout car en des quelques jours
après sa propre élection par le peuple
français
donc le président de la république a
reçu un mandat des français qui l'a
sollicitée sur un certain nombre
d'engagements et il prend il fait le
choix d'exposer à l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale elle même a été
en partie renouvelé
comment il compte conduire ce mandat et
comment il compte agir sur les
principaux points qui sont des
préoccupations et les attentes de la
france en particulier un meilleur
développement économique et un
renforcement de l'emploi donc ça me
paraît juste logique et cohérent que il
s'adresse d'abord à nous et à travers
nous naturellement aux français que nous
représentons conjointement avec lui que
vous comprenez à ceux qui boycottent
dans ces conditions qu'ils estiment que
cela déséquilibre nos institutions
non je pense que c'est une mauvaise
compréhension de nos institutions de la
part d'ailleurs de certains collègues
qui pourrait mieux les connaître puisque
sur ces l'application de la constitution
et il me semble que c'est simplement une
façon d'attirer un peu l'attention alors
que évidemment le sujet principal qui
intéresse je crois la collectivité des
parlementaires et les français c'est ce
à quoi s'engage le président de la
république comment ils nous expliquent
le chemin qu'il veut suivre et auquel il
nous associe donc je trouve que nous
sommes plutôt dans notre rôle en
l'écoutant et ensuite nos présidents de
groupe en donnant leurs sentiments par
rapport à cette prise de position ne
fait pas de sens de premier ministre un
simple collaborateur
non ça c'est une mauvaise compréhension
des institutions
il vous a pas échappé que le premier
ministre conduit l'action du
gouvernement et qu'il est responsable
devant le parlement donc c'est
l'application de la constitution ville
c'est pas inutile de la lire un peu
quand on fait de la politique il a un
programme gouvernemental il a une action
qu'il va conduire qu'il va ensuite que
nous allons à laquelle nous allons nous
associer en votant ou non sur les
budgets sur les projets de loi et donc
il ya un déroulement à mon avis naturel
et je pense que si vous nous interroger
des uns et les autres après ces deux
interventions aujourd'hui et
main beaucoup reconnaîtront qu'il ya à
chaque fois du contenu des choses qui
sont des décisions qui sont des projets
et sur lesquelles il ya matière en effet
à débattre et un s'engager merci
beaucoup à la recherche effectivement ce
que l'on verra